it is the final weekend of campaigning
for candidates running in the midterm
elections Republicans are hoping to ride
a wave of voter discontent over
inflation the economy and crime to take
back control of the House of
Representatives and the Senate if
Democrats lose just one chamber of com
Congress it would likely hamper
President Joe Biden's agenda for the
next two years and before the 2022 races
are even decided the 2024 election
appears to be heating up CBS News has
learned that former president Donald
Trump is considering running for the
White House again and could make the
announcement sometime this month some of
the most fiercely competitive races are
in the home stretch Caitlyn Huey Burns
is in Philadelphia with the latest
Caitlin good morning
hi Michelle and good morning from the
center of the political Universe in a
sign of how critical Pennsylvania is in
these midterm elections the biggest
names in politics are descending upon
the state today President Biden and
former president Obama are coming here
to Philadelphia to campaign for John
fetterman and in another part of the
state former president Donald Trump is
coming to campaign for Dr Mehmet Oz this
is a very close Senate race that could
determine control of Congress
despite the political headwinds
President Biden sounded optimistic
yesterday before boarding Air Force One
in California this is the most important
election we ever had in our lifetime in
the final days of the midterm campaign
key races remain tight Republican Senate
candidate Herschel Walker is in a dead
heat with Democratic senator Rafael
Warnock Herschel Walkers wrong for
Georgia and I think people all across
the state Democrats Republicans and
independents can't see it I will tell
you all this if I lived in Pennsylvania
I would have already cast my vote for
John fetterman here in Pennsylvania John
fetterman secured an endorsement from
Oprah Winfrey whose show Once helped
catapult Dr Oz to start up she's an icon
I mean it's it's unbelievable betterman
has been responding to voter concerns
about the economy and inflation by
swiping at Corporate America I think
it's even much more critical to push
back against the kind of a kind of the
corporate greed and the price gouging is
well true Oz has been focusing his
closing message here around Rising crime
we have families all over the
Commonwealth worried about crime so much
so they won't send their kids outside
losing Pennsylvania would put
Republicans hopes of gaining control of
the senate in Jeopardy they would need
to instead flip two other Battlegrounds
that's why the president and his two
recent predecessors are all descending
upon the state today
and while Trump is here campaigning for
other candidates he's got 2024 on his
mind he's expected to announce a third
presidential bid as soon as maybe around
Thanksgiving so today's dueling rallies
could be a preview of what's to come and
Jeff So It Begins
yes so it begins and so it continues on
and on Caitlyn Huey Burns thank you very
much